back too back here
in the nba bubble welcome to the
playoffs
the lakers are back where they belong
lebron
say it with your chest we feel different
dawg we feel different
danny green with a nice defensive play
have a night marquis
morris caruso one on one he dumped it
and the laker bench is going
nuts rondo brings in anthony davis three
for the win
he got it oh denied by
howard
playoff rondo is real the lakers back to
the nba finals
kuzma finds davis for the slam huge
three by kcp
it's good anthony davis with the dagger
the lakers are the world champion their
17th title the sheer joy it's gonna be a
long
long night credit to this group right
here these group of players and got it
done
to hear that and we're nba champions
you can't even put into words for me to
be a part of such a historical franchise
it's an unbelievable feeling
it means a lot let this trophy serve
as a reminder of when we come together
believe in each other incredible things
can happen
laker nation when it's safe i look
forward
to celebrating with you
[Music]
we've waited until now
because our banners have always been
about our fans
it it's so good to hear you guys
together
and be together as family again
we we've been awarded our trophy
the players have their rings our final
piece of business
is to commemorate our 2020 nba
championship
is to honor our fans with the banner
i'd like to turn it over
to our leader and team captain lebron
james
thank you genie um on behalf of uh
you know my teammates coaching staff
training staff
uh myself and other team captain a.d
we would not uh send this banner to the
rafters without you guys and i know
we're missing a lot of our laker
faithful but
um this is absolutely for you guys we
said we would not reveal this banner
until we had some of you guys in the
seat so
this is you guys moment we had our ring
night we wanted you guys there but we
made sure we saved the banner for y'all
so
we love you guys and uh on the road to
uh back to back starts in about a week
so
let's get going
banner coming down in three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the 2020 nba world champion los angeles
flager
thank you janie and lebron and now
welcome number three
anthony davis
like a nation man what a feeling
i never thought that i would be raising
one of these banners man
and it's all because of you guys all
because of you your continued
your continued support for me my
teammates the coaching staff
you know before the hiatus you guys are
loud in the building
even when we went to the bubble you guys
every day every night come in
and be on the screens and we see you
guys cheering for us man that means a
lot to us
and without you guys
without you guys we wouldn't be able to
raise this banner or had his trophy
behind me so i appreciate you guys and
like brian said let's get it going to
try to repeat
thank you anthony laker fans
one more time for the 2020 nba
world champion the los angeles lakers
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
still trading